Jean-Luc Picard is back for a new adventure
in Star Trek: Picard, once again boldly going
where no one has gone before.
The CBS All-Access show is filled with callbacks
to Star Trek past, including some that might
elude even the most dedicated of fans.
The first episode of Star Trek: Picard opens
to the music of Irving Berlin, as Bing Crosby
croons the lyrics to "Blue Skies."
It's a curious song choice for a show set
in the distant future, but the nearly century-old
song holds a surprising amount of significance
for Jean-Luc Picard.
Early on in Star Trek: Nemesis, the final
film in the Next Generation movie series,
Lieutenant Commander Data channels the classic
crooners of the past by performing "Blue Skies"
at the wedding of Will Riker and Deanna Troi.
Toward the end of the film, before Data is
destroyed sacrificing himself along with the
Reman ship Scimitar, Data attempts to transfer
his memories to B-4, an earlier prototype
of the android made by his creator, Dr. Noonian
Soong.
Unfortunately, B-4 is not nearly as advanced
as Data, and it appears the transfer was a
failure until B-4 begins softly singing "Blue
Skies" to himself at the end of the movie.
Picard's reaction in Nemesis indicates that
he suspects there may be some of Data still
alive after all, a thread that is carried
forward into the first episode of Picard,
in which the former captain not only visits
with Data in his dreams, but speculates that
the "essence" of Data now lives on in a new
form.
Since The Next Generation ended with a poker
game, it's only fitting that Picard should
begin with one.
The first episode sees Jean-Luc and Data playing
cards aboard the Enterprise, engaged in the
same sort of conversation we've seen them
participate in countless times before: analyzing
yet another of Data's attempts to appear more
human.
This time, Picard is sizing up Data's humanity
in the form of a poker tell.
Data is dilating one pupil in order to fool
the Captain into believing he has a good hand,
while Picard deduces that his real tell is
when he does nothing at all.
The scene helps viewers feel immediately at
home in the new show, bringing back settings,
themes, and characters that have already been
familiar for decades, but it also calls back
to the final episode of The Next Generation,
"All Good Things..."
After skipping through time and saving all
life in the universe, the final scene finds
the crew of the Enterprise engaged in their
regular poker game.
They're surprised when Picard arrives and
asks to join, but welcome him to the table,
and the series ends with the Captain dealing
the cards while saying, "The sky's the limit."
In Picard, the poker game makes it clear that
we're picking up where the previous show left
off, and setting it to "Blue Skies" could
even be calling back to Picard's final line.
A poker game also opens the Next Generation
episode "The Measure of a Man," in which Data's
humanity is put on trial.
In that episode, Data also uses poker as an
analogy to try to illustrate the difference
between knowledge and memories.
The themes of that episode feel relevant to
Picard a sad future in which synthetics like
Data have been deemed too dangerous to exist,
and have been outlawed entirely.
When Jean-Luc is getting ready for his interview,
evaluating his appearance in the mirror, we
get a brief glimpse of a cream-colored fedora
with a black band hanging on a coat rack behind
him.
From the perspective of the camera, the hat
almost appears to be sitting on Picard's head
at a jaunty angle.
What at first glance could be mistaken for
just a random piece of set dressing actually
hearkens back to one of Picard's favorite
holodeck characters the 20th century detective,
Dixon Hill.
The gumshoe was one of young Jean-Luc's childhood
heroes, and Picard donned the private investigator's
characteristic trench coat and fedora on numerous
occasions during The Next Generation's run,
most notably during the season one episode
"The Big Goodbye."
In that episode, the simulated mystery Picard
is trying to solve on the holodeck involves
the death of a young woman, foreshadowing
the real-life puzzle he finds himself caught
up in as Picard begins.
During Picard's fateful interview about the
Romulan supernova and his retirement from
Starfleet, the interviewer mentions that the
Utopia Planitia shipyards on Mars were completely
destroyed in the synthetic attacks during
the supernova.
It's a passing comment in a laundry list of
the catastrophic events that brought Picard
and the Federation to their now-opposing positions.
But "Utopia Planitia" isn't just some random
futuristic words thrown in for emphasis the
shipyard has a lot of significance in Star
Trek lore.
The Utopia Planitia shipyards served as one
of the primary Starfleet ship construction
sites across several Star Trek series.
Among the many ships that were constructed
there were the USS Voyager, the USS Defiant
which featured prominently in Star Trek: Deep
Space Nine and of course, the flagship herself,
the USS Enterprise 1701-D.
Further, Commander Benjamin Sisko served for
several years at Utopia Planitia before taking
command of the Deep Space Nine space station.
"I would have thought that after three years
spent at the Utopia Planitia yards, that you
would be ready for a change."
Jean-Luc has several dreams of Data during
the first episode of Star Trek: Picard, but
one of the most pivotal moments occurs when
he dreams of Data painting a woman in white
robes gazing out over a turbulent sea.
This dream cues Picard to go find a painting
the real Data gifted to him 30 years earlier,
which to Picard's extreme surprise depicts
the same young woman who showed up in Picard's
vineyard earlier in the episode.
While Data explored a lot of artistic pursuits
over the course of The Next Generation, his
painting in Picard seems to call back specifically
to the sixth-season episode "Birthright, Part
1," in which Data experiences a confusing
vision and asks Captain Picard how he should
go about interpreting it.
Picard urges him to explore what he saw in
a way that feels meaningful to him, and Data
decides to use painting to explore the images
in his head.
Ultimately, after painting dozens of pictures,
Data determines that he has accessed a new
level of his programming and can now dream,
which he resolves to continue doing henceforth.
It seems only fitting that Data's painting
pursuits would come full circle in Picard,
with Jean-Luc using the image of Data painting
in his dreams to find meaning in what's happening
in his real life.
Even in death, it seems, his old Lieutenant
Commander is still able to help him out.
When Picard goes to visit his vault in the
Starfleet Archives, we get a brief glimpse
of two prominently displayed model ships,
neither of which is the Enterprise.
The first is the USS Stargazer, the first
starship Picard ever commanded.
This was the ship on which he would first
perform the battle tactic that eventually
came to be called the "Picard Maneuver," using
a brief burst from the ship's warp drive to
confuse the sensors of the opposing ship,
making it appear as though the Stargazer was
in two places at the same time.
While Picard sometimes spoke disparagingly
of the Stargazer, a ramshackle ship with an
overworked crew, he did confess to occasionally
longing for the way things used to be.
"There are times when I would give almost
anything to command the Stargazer again."
The second model is the captain's yacht from
the Enterprise-E, christened the Cousteau.
The Cousteau was featured in the third TNG
movie, Star Trek: Insurrection, in which Picard
and the crew of the Enterprise stood against
the Federation to keep them from forcibly
relocating a peaceful species so that they
could plunder their planet's resources.
In Insurrection, Picard temporarily resigns
from Starfleet, disgusted by their abandoning
of the Prime Directive and their dismissal
of innocent lives in the name of their own
self-interest which is exactly the same issue
that ultimately led to his permanent resignation
following the Romulan supernova.
There is also a Klingon weapon in Picard's
vault in the Starfleet Archives, a curved
blade called a bat'leth.
The Next Generation often featured Lieutenant
Commander Worf training and fighting with
a bat'leth that had been in his family for
generations.
It's unclear exactly where Picard's bat'leth
came from; while it's possible it's Worf's,
it could also be one that Picard came by through
his other dealings with the Klingons.
Picard notably served as Arbiter of Succession
at the request of the Klingon leader K'mpec
during the Next Generation episodes "Reunion"
and "Redemption," and it's possible his high
standing with the Klingon Empire led at some
point to him receiving his own bat'leth.
Regardless of where Picard's bat'leth came
from, the weapon's presence in his vault serves
as a reminder that Picard is highly respected
among the Klingons, who used to be the Federation's
fiercest enemies.
That theme feels significant to Star Trek:
Picard, which reveals that the former officer
resigned from Starfleet over their treatment
of the Romulans, who stepped into the role
of primary Trek villains after the Federation
finally made peace with the Klingons.
One of the final treasured items that Jean-Luc
Picard has kept stored away in his vault all
these years is the banner that the children
of the Enterprise made for him to celebrate
"Captain Picard Day," an annual event in which
the children of the starship honor its captain
through original artwork.
While Picard was reluctant to participate
in Captain Picard Day while aboard the Enterprise,
it would seem that he may have appreciated
it more than he let on, if he kept the banner
for decades after leaving his post.
We witness Picard receiving the banner in
The Next Generation's season 7 episode "The
Pegasus," which sees the crew of the Enterprise
facing off against the Romulans to recover
a Starfleet ship near the neutral zone.
During the course of the episode, it becomes
clear that Starfleet violated their peace
treaty with the Romulans and tried to cover
it up, but Picard refuses to go along with
the deception, revealing the truth to the
Romulans and siding against his Starfleet
colleagues.
In short, this is yet another Easter egg in
Picard's first episode that calls back to
a time when our hero took a stand against
the Federation, possibly foreshadowing that
the one-time captain and Starfleet are about
to find themselves at odds once more.
When Picard travels to the Daystrom Institute
in Okinawa in order to dig into the possibility
that Dahj may be a flesh and blood synthetic,
he meets with Dr. Agnes Jurati, who assures
him that sentient flesh and blood synthetics
are nothing more than a forgotten pipe dream.
Jurati then mentions that she was recruited
by Dr. Bruce Maddox, and that the two of them
had worked together to create a sentient android
similar to Data.
She says they'd been close until the synthetic
ban, after which Maddox disappeared.
If the name of the missing scientist sounds
familiar, there's a good reason for that.
Bruce Maddox first appeared in the Next Generation
season 2 episode "The Measure of a Man," in
which he argued against Data's sentience in
the hopes of being able to override his free
will and study him.
Opposing Maddox was none other than Captain
Jean-Luc Picard, who presented a moving and
ultimately, victorious case for Data's personhood.
Mentioning Maddox in an episode already rife
with themes of sentience, identity, free will,
and individuality feels like a very deliberate
nod to one of The Next Generation's most fascinating
core debates, and hints that we haven't heard
the last of either side of this argument.
When Picard is telling Dahj his theory about
her origins, she tells Picard about a hybrid
orchid that her father engineered, splicing
two genuses and naming "the offspring" after
her.
Later, Picard mentions to Dr. Jurati that
Data always wanted a daughter.
Both lines together seem to be a direct reference
to "The Offspring," a season 3 episode of
The Next Generation in which Data constructs
an android daughter named Lal from his own
design.
In "The Offspring," Lal evolves quickly, surpassing
even Data's abilities in a short amount of
time and revealing that she can feel emotion,
but ultimately her experiences wind up overloading
her positronic brain.
Despite Data's best efforts, he is unable
to save her.
Data then downloads Lal's memories into his
own neural net, so that in a way, she can
live on through him.
"The Offspring" also sees Picard side against
the Federation once again, when a Starfleet
Admiral attempts to claim Lal for scientific
research, and Picard refuses to let her go.
Dahj's journey in Picard's first episode mirrors
Lal's in many ways in how Picard tried to
protect her, and ultimately, in how she died
after only being truly awake for a brief time.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Trek:
Picard are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.